- All right thank you
so much for joining us
for this sixth in the series
of the Yale development
Dialogues Economic Policy
lessons from history
today we're going to be
discussing sustainable development
on an urbanizing planet.
These are virtual panel discussions
hosted by the Yale Economic Growth Center
the South Asian Studies Council
and the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs.
I'm Catherine Cheney,
a journalist focused
on global development,
and I'll be your moderator today.
I'm joined by panelists
Sunil Amrith, Kate Brown,
Edward Glaeser, and Rory Stewart
whom I'll introduce in just a moment.
But first I wanna give a bit of context
on why we're talking
about this topic today.
So throughout history, as many of you know
or perhaps may study
population growth and urbanization
have been presented as a problem
whether it's about putting
a strain on resources
or driving the climate crisis
but historical and contemporary examples
show us how cities can
in fact, mitigate sprawl
reduce carbon emissions, and
in fact, foster biodiversity.
And we'll hear some examples of that.
Urbanization seems inevitable.
And as one of our panelists
at Glaeser puts it
in a conversation we had just
preparing for this session.
There's no pathway out of
poverty into prosperity
that does not run through city streets.
Urbanization again is happening.
So the question is what
role can cities play
in the search for green
solutions to poverty?
Today our panelists will
offer different perspectives
on what elements of organization are
and are not conducive to
sustainable development.
So I'll go ahead and
introduce our panelists
and then we'll hear from each of them
and move into a conversation.
And I just want to remind
everyone attending this webinar
to please put your questions into the chat
into the Q&A function here in Zoom,
throughout the conversation.
And then I'll know what's
coming what's resonating
and work your questions in
throughout the conversation.
So keep those coming.
To introduce our panelists
first, I'd like to
introduce to Sunil Amrith.
He's the Renu and Anand Dhawan
Professor of History at Yale
and current Chair of the
South Asian Studies Council.
His research focuses on histories
and environment migration in public health
across South and Southeast Asia.
And he helped to put together this topic
and this panel for today,
so thank you, Sunil.
We'll hear more from him in a moment.
And Ed Glaeser is a Professor
of Economics at Harvard University.
His research focuses on cities,
economic growth, law and economics.
In particular his work has focused
on the determinants of city growth
and the role of cities as
centers of ideas, transmission.
He has served as Taubman Center
for State and Local Government
and Director of the Rappaport
Institute for Greater Boston.
Kate Brown is a professor
of Science Technology and Society at MIT.
Her research explores where
history science technology
and bio politics converged to
create large scale disasters
and modernist wastelands,
the author of four books most recently
"Manual for Survival: A
Chernobyl Guide to the Future"
She's currently exploring the history
of what she calls plant
people, which we'll learn more
about who understood long before others
that plants communicate
have sensory capacities
and possess the capacity
for memory and intelligence.
And Rory Stewart is a Senior Fellow
at the Yale Jackson
Institute for Global Affairs
where he focuses on
contemporary politics in crisis
and on international development
and intervention in fragile
and conflict affected States.
Stewart, as many of you know
if you've tuned into these past webinars
previously started as
a UK Secretary of State
for international development
where he doubled the UK investment
in international climate and environment.
So I'd like to begin with
Sunil, who I mentioned is one
of the co-hosts of the
Yale Development Dialogues
and really advocated for
this topic is one to take on.
So Sunil why this topic, why now
and why is this something that benefits
from bringing historical perspectives
together with practitioner perspectives?
- So if we think about
where we've been so far in this series
yet we started with a couple
of sessions on the pandemic
and the implications of the
pandemic for development.
More recently, we've thought
about green pathways out of poverty.
And it seemed to me that this
the question of cities
brings those together
in a very interesting way is
particularly at this moment.
And I do think we can benefit very much
from the kind of dialogue
we've had between historians
practitioners economists
on the question of cities
and sustainability in the
context of development.
So about a year ago when
we were about a month
or two into the pandemic
I think we all saw these
photographs and I'm on social media
and the news of wildlife
returning to the city.
There were photos of Delhi
from where you could see the Himalayas
for the first time in 20 years.
And on the one hand, I think
this was a wake up call
for so many of us who perhaps
ignored the biodiversity
that has always lived in plain sight
in cities that we inhabit.
But perhaps there was also a sense
that this was self-indulgent that,
here we were talking
about wildlife returning
to the city when people are
suffering and losing their jobs.
And in a way I think it also
there was a backlash against it
as there always has been
this idea that green urbanism
is in some ways an indulgence.
And I wanted to think about that,
the history of that in ways that
I'm looking forward to
hearing from Kate about that
another way in which I
can see this link is,
we've been told many times,
and I think we're all convinced that
one of the root causes of the pandemic
is the shifting wild frontier
the shifting frontier between
human beings and animals,
particularly wildlife.
Again, we've tended to think of that
frontier as being out there,
but that frontier is also right
at the heart of the cities
that we inhabit that frontier
is in the food systems
that feed us to do is that frontier
is in the ways that we live
that frontier lives in the
implications of urban density
or different kinds of urban density.
So I also wanted to touch on that.
And finally, as a historian myself
I have been struck by the
very ambivalent role of cities
within the entire project of development
since the middle of the 20th century.
Now on the one hand
precisely as as I put it
every path to prosperity runs
through the city streets.
And if you think about
development in the 1950s and '60s
not just in the eyes of experts
but even if you think about
Hindi cinema in the 1950s
the story of development is a story
of leaving the countryside
and moving to the city.
On the other hand, I think we've seen
the second half of the 20th
century in Asia and Africa
a very deep anti-urbanism
And I think you find
this in India and China,
this idea that the soul of the nation
lives in the countryside
that the countryside is the place
for sustenance and provisioning.
And until the 1980s you
can actually see that
India and China to take those two examples
had much lower rates of urbanization
than most economists predicted
or that economic theory
would have predicted.
And then only in the late 20th century
in a sense that the shackles come off.
So I'd be very interested
in thinking about the history of ideas
about the role of cities
within development as well.
- Thank you and that's
something I'm looking forward
to hearing from Rory on also,
what are these conversations looking like
in development circles
but I wanna bring Ed into this
and Ed cities as we
have as we've discussed,
are often depicted as
enemies of the environment
but your view is it doesn't
have to be that way.
So can you expand on what it looks like
when it isn't that way?
- Certainly thank you.
And thank you for, including
me in this conversation
which I've been really looking forward to,
I wanna jump off on Sunil's comment
on the thread of anti urbanisms
that often shows up in
the developing world.
Of course, Gandhi famously
said that the future of India
is in its villages not in its cities.
And I cannot tell you how many times
I've been in a developing
world politician's office
and he's asked me great
you're an expert on cities.
Tell me how I stop all these poor people
from coming to my city
and screwing it up, right?
That is frequently the
line that I've gotten.
And I think that's a terrible mistake
even not only obviously our cities
places of economic prosperity
but when you look at the urban,
rural life satisfaction gap.
So the happiness gap,
that gap is nonexistent
in the developed world
but in the developing world, it's huge.
And the country actually
where you have the largest
life satisfaction gap
in the world in our data list is India.
That in fact, India has the biggest gap
between urban happiness
and non-urban unhappiness.
Now, one of the reasons why people state
for being anti urbanists is that
they see urbanism as being
antithetical to the environment.
I sometimes call this the Lorax Fallacy
after the Dr Seuss book,
which depicts a city building
running rough shot over a natural habitat.
And I think part of the reason
for that mistake is a
tendency confuse urbanization
with the process of wealth accumulation
the process of economic development.
It is absolutely true that
as countries get richer
they are gonna use more carbon
unless we do a lot against it, right?
And that's somewhat inevitable
but we have to talk about how minimizing,
how we can minimize that
by contrast urbanization is
really about densification.
The economic definition of the city
is the absence of physical
space between people and firms.
And closeness is a way of
reducing carbon emissions
not a way of increasing them right?
Back of the envelope number that I like.
And it's about 10 years old now.
So take it with a grain of salt
but if the great growing
economies of India
and China see their per
capita carbon emissions rise
to that scene in the
sprawling United States
global carbon emissions
go up by about a tenfold.
If they stop at the level
seen in high wealthy
but hyperdense Hong Kong
global carbon emissions
go up by about 25%.
It's 125% versus 25% sorry.
So it's really a massive
gap in terms of this.
Another way of seeing this is
is if you compare the
brownest city in China
in terms of its household emissions
as opposed to its total
industrial emissions
it is one fifth of the
amount of carbon per capita
then the greenest city
in the United States.
So there's really a huge
amount of gap is there.
Now why is it the density
is relatively positive
for the environment?
There really are two main things
that we see both in the
US and Chinese data.
The first is the size of the dwelling.
Typically in cities, people
are occupying smaller dwellings
even holding income and
family size constant.
And so those smaller
dwellings just mean a lot
less energy involved in
heating and cooling in China.
They don't actually cool typically
except for the very wealthiest
households, but they do heat.
And consequently, the
cities of Northern China
are much more carbon intensive
than the cities of Southern China.
The second reason is of
course moving people around.
And this is a big tension
in terms of bringing
biodiversity into the city.
That in fact the strongest prediction
of how much carbon you
emit in your everyday life
is how far the distances are
between you and other people
between you and your job
between you and the
places that you wanna go.
The more biodiversity
that you bring in
between people in cities,
the more that you're expanding
the distances between people
and the more that you end up having people
to drive longer distances
and take longer commutes
in different ways.
So for those reasons
there's really a substantial
carbon emissions gap
between people living in central New York
versus people living in suburbs.
So I think I'll stop there
but the central point being
there's nothing wrong with
density for carbon emissions.
In fact it's a good thing for
us to be close to one another.
The challenge is as the world gets rich
and I think we all want
the world to get rich
how we can make sure
that the world gets rich
in a way that doesn't involve
massive amounts of energy use
that put the planet in peril.
- Thank you, Ed and to build on that point
I know Kate brings a unique
insights from her research
and lessons from history
so Kate, I'd love your take.
As Ed mentioned, closeness and
and density can actually
have positive implications
for the environment, but
how do we steer it that way?
So what are some insights
you have to share
in terms of ensuring that urbanization
is not in conflict with
but perhaps in support
preserving biodiversity?
- Yeah, well, let's look at
the past as I'm an historian.
In Paris in 1900 5,000
Parisian farmers fed
2 million Parisians
with leftover to be shipped
to London and Washington DC
where I am right now, soil
migrants migrated up to DC
from the South where they lost their farms
because the soil was exhausted
and they could no longer produce.
And they started farming
there, a periphery of DC in DC
but where they were allowed
to live as African-Americans
and the tax records and ho housing records
have an amazing fact
that among people in this
and across the region of DC
rates of homeowner occupancy
a significant indicator
of financial stability
were some of the highest in the city
59% in 1940 versus 33%
for white residents.
So black residents of
Anacostia denied equal access
to housing education,
public infrastructure,
financing and jobs were able
to pay down on their homes.
When most other white neighbors
were not able to do that.
And they managed to do that
by growing their own food
and trading some of it locally.
Look at the Soviet Union,
1990, I was living in Moscow.
Everybody talked about famine.
Soviet agriculture had collapsed.
Same thing happened in Cuba,
but what did people do?
They got on the commuter trains.
And they went out to the peri
urban areas had small plots
and they grew their own potatoes
by 1996 91% of all
potatoes grown in Russia
were grown by small plot
gardeners, dacha gardeners
and 1.5% of the arable
land in the country.
So we're not talking about
that we need a lot of space.
What's really sort of amazing
is that people abandoned
or neglected by their government
and managed to come up
with their own technological solutions.
These are not primitive people
that the Parisian farmers
use the mass of course,
maneuver that gathered in the city.
They use the urban walls
but to have wall orchards
in that way created
their own micro-climates
and produce their own soils.
And then they ended up selling those soils
to farmers outside of the city.
They had so many great nutrients.
So what's does that matter today?
I think we have one of the
greatest biodiversity ponds
we have right now
is a biodiversity of the
human gut microbiome.
The people in industrial North have this
really streamlined
biodiversity in their gut
and that has all kinds
of health repercussions
and starts in childhood
and continues into old age.
So how do we what we've
basically done in cities
and suburbs is
and in the conventional
industrial farming areas
is engineered ourselves
to the very margins of our environments.
And so gardening puts
people microbially back
into their environments,
and you can do it in very tiny
spaces where you have these
or we've got records of people
producing masses of food
six crops a year on a
10th of an acre of land.
So I appreciate what Ed is talking about
in terms of density and I don't
think it has to annihilate
the prospect of biodiversity.
In fact, if you look at American cities
most of our a good portion, let me say 30.
Sometimes 50% of our real estate
is given as devoted to cars,
moving them and parking them.
And most of those cars sit
around 90% of the time.
Those cities of the future
can't have cars anymore.
I think that the Netherlands
have just decided to ban cars
in their major cities.
So what if this doesn't
take an act of God.
It doesn't take an,
even an act of Congress,
but just a municipal
ordinance shift devote
that territory that's been
given over to parking,
devoted to plants.
Every new apartment has
to have a gardening plot
rather than a parking lot.
I think we could have a whole new world.
I agree with you.
And I'm curious, we
hopefully, in our discussion
we can talk about while that is certainly
an appealing vision of what
our future could look like.
What are the real challenges
that stand in the way
in terms of implementing that vision
which actually brings me into Rory
and Rory we've heard that urbanization
and sustainable development biodiversity
do not have to be in
conflict with one another.
In fact, they can support one another.
And yet, as Sunil mentioned
cities often play an ambivalent role in
in the project of development.
And in fact, if anything,
maybe there's an anti
organism lens that many take.
So what was your experience
working within DFID
now the STDO in the UK in terms
of what this looked like in
an international aid agenda?
- So let me first preface by saying
I'm gonna start with a
focus on the UK aid agency
but it's worth looking at DFID
because it was one of the most
thoughtful progressive agencies.
And to some extent, the way
that it looked at the world
is characteristic of the way
that many people in the World Bank
and other financial agencies
looked at the world.
The first thing to understand is that
at the core of the work of a DFID
and many of these bilateral agencies
is the idea of focusing
on the very poorest people in the world
in particular, the
better focusing on people
who are living on under $2 a day.
And that means that so
much of the programming
is about trying to reach those individuals
that has meant for example,
the real passion for cash transfers
an idea of giving cash to families
in order to transform their lives,
either in a monthly payment
or a one-time payment to help
them set up a micro business
following on from that
will be large programs,
particularly around primary education
and primary health care.
And a lot of the energy of the agencies
is absorbed in that kind of work.
What isn't done by these
agencies traditionally
are very expensive large
infrastructure projects
that's become less and
less fashionable, right?
There are other ways of funding that
some of that from the private sector
some of that from development banks,
but by and large the idea has been
to take the emphasis off, dams, roads
and onto the question of how
you work with very poor people.
Now, fast forward, what
is the problem then
that we confront the problem effectively
is that that model of
working with very poor people
basically in people's minds
and someone like Tanzania
has a rural feeling right?
The general impression is that
you're turning up in a remote
rural area where people have
very relaxes to services.
And you're worrying about how to set up
a primary health clinic
or a primary school
and how to work particularly on,
for example agricultural
extension development work,
making sure that people
in those communities can
get more crops out of
a given amount of land
and maybe get some loans to enable them
to access fertilizers,
pesticides, et cetera.
But in fact, the reality of
increasingly what's happening
in some of that Tanzania is
people are moving to cities.
So you turn up in a city
and you find that 85% youth unemployment
you find it an incredible number of people
in their late teens and
early 20s who swarmed in
as sort made swarmed as a bad word
but have common and very large number
it's from rural areas
and are struggling to
find any form of job.
And the city is expanding
unbelievably quickly.
I mean, one of the challenges
in the developing world
is that when I was
first in Kabul, in 2001,
the total population of the city
was approximately 400,000 people.
Today the population of
Kabul will be up pushing
probably four or 5 million, and
that's happened in 20 years.
And when that happens,
everything changes right?
The water vanishes, because
you start tapping a water table
which simply doesn't have
enough water to keep the city.
That sounds great.
There is no sewage infrastructure.
There's no proper pipe,
water infrastructure
informal settlements
springing up on every hillside
and often collapsing and landslides.
There is no provision of public space.
There's no green space that's made parks.
Nobody's really thinking
about mass transit
subsidy no underground system
getting into this neighbor.
So what does the development agency do?
And they're the problem
and I'll finish on this
they are the problem comes,
which is the mindset of
the development agency
is still very much focused
on the very poorest people in villages.
And thinking about how you
can change someone's life
with let's say 40, $50 a year.
Suddenly you are in the
environment of Kabul
or Dar es Salaam
Well, what is actually needed
is literally billions of
dollars worth of investment
in laying the basic infrastructure
for functioning city
and making some very,
very difficult decisions
challenging property developers
who are building very dangerous,
unsafe, unsound buildings,
thinking about how you could
generate a sustainable urbanism
thinking about how you might protect
some of the historical
heritage of the city
thinking about how you
create your green spaces
how you get people walking, right?
And then that is an enormous problem
and enormous problem in mobilizing
sufficient resources to do this
because this stuff is
incredibly expensive.
I mean, creating an underground system
is an astonishingly expensive
thing to do in any city.
And very difficult for
people psychologically
to justify you're in a very poor country.
What are you doing spending
literally billions of dollars, right?
To set up one of these systems.
And yet you have to do it.
If you don't make that investment now,
credibly difficult to retrofit.
I mean, almost impossible now in Kabul
to work out how you actually
put that infrastructure
in because so much rapid development
has happened in the last 20 years,
that it's very difficult to work out
where the spaces to get the sewage
and the water turning left lane
and underground system
(mumbles)
Okay, I'm gonna finish on that
because I want this to be more
of a conversation in my lecture.
- Yeah.
- But,
somewhere in the problem is
different we'll talk about urbanism
but it will find it very very difficult
to make the types of investments necessary
to really help our slum
carbon in the future.
- Thank you, Rory.
Well, that's exactly
where I'd love to begin.
I just love to bring any of our panelists
and hearing this challenge from Rory
that the mindset of development agencies
is focused on the very
poorest living in villages,
not some of the challenges in cities,
any thoughts from any of you
just reactions to why that is
or whether that could change.
And if it were to change
where lessons from
history might be valuable
- I don't think that's a mistake at all.
So in terms of disclosure,
I need to need to say
that since we're talking about different
that I co lead the
international growth centers
cities program, which is different funded.
So we certainly do have a deep
gratitude to two different.
And I think that in terms
of the flow of funds
at least given current development budgets
that's exactly right.
On other hand, it is also appropriate
for entities like the IGC to do research
as I do on infrastructure
in the developing world
in particular infrastructure
in developing world cities
and to try and help those
countries figure out
how to make those systems functional.
I mean, for example, you
know, Rory has pointed out
the unbelievable price of
underground subway systems.
There's an old joke that 50 years
of transportation economics at Harvard
can be boiled down to four
words, bus, good, train bad.
And in fact, bus rapid transit
particularly the developing
world is a vastly
more cost-effective
means of working things.
That being said, I think
in a post COVID world
there is a view that at
least it's a view that I have
that in fact, COVID
should be a wake up call
that the wealthy world should actually
especially the United States
should massively increase its commitment
to developing world budgets.
And that investment should be motivated
by primarily by concerns
for global public health.
And I don't think spending on roads
is obviously part of that
but spending on sewers might very well be
if you have the view that
currently having unhealthy water systems
leads to the proliferation of superbugs
that are antibiotic resistant.
And it is amazing that
the work of my colleague,
Dr. Marcella Alsan at the Kennedy School
finds that in Hyderabad
the number of women who enter the hospital
simply because they were pregnant
but were then tested for
antibiotic resistant diseases.
The numbers of them who
had them in their guts
was just enormous, right?
So we are really sitting
on a time bomb here
and investing in water could
be a way of fixing that.
So I think those forms of
investment makes sense.
And I think it is possible
that you might even want things
that are more of a quid pro quo,
which is you get the money in exchange
for a serious monitoring devices
that actually look out
for outbreaks of disease
or for the same type of hygienic policies
that we had in the 19th century
that kept animals away from humans, right?
So part of the critical
thing is we wanna sort of
separate out nature and humanity
so that we don't have this
sort of cross species,
zoonotic diseases striking as we've
currently the whole world
has been suffering from
- Any other reactions
to that Sunil or Kate?
Kate I see you wanna jump in?
- Yeah I think I'd go
in the other direction,
top-down development you all can tell me
the history as well as anyone.
It hasn't really worked
what I'm talking about
a working class, people coming
up with their own solutions.
So again, take these
peripheral neighborhoods
of urban America.
People didn't have sewers,
they didn't have roads
they didn't have streets, they
didn't have garbage pickup.
And what did they do?
They took their own night's soil.
They took their kitchen scraps.
They took the scraps from their animals
that they lived closely
with not huge feed lots
where animals were being fed antibiotics
but their own five, 10
animals, chickens in a hog.
And they recycled those nutrients.
They broke the metabolic
rift that was impoverishing
both rural areas and
countryside, excuse me
what rural areas or impoverished
people flood to cities
as these new heights.
When the new sewer systems come in
where does that sewage go?
It goes into the local water sources
and creates these algae blooms, kills fish
another resource to plead it
another some biodiversity gone,
in American cities right now
we don't have a lot of
horsemen, but we have a lot
of human mover and farmers take
that they know that's cooked
at really high degrees
and farmers use that.
We don't really it's called biosols.
We don't often recognize that
but we're growing food
in human VCs right now.
That's a device that was created
by working urban farmers century ago.
It's a good idea.
I think we need to stop
using the failed cities
in the Western world as a model
as a standard for failures
exported elsewhere.
We've done that for a 100 years.
I think it's time to move on.
- And can I ask you in terms
of if there is a model?
So if the model is not these failed cities
Hong Kong came up
earlier, can we talk about
what are the models to look toward?
- Can I just come in here
I'd love to sort of bring you
this is a fascinating panel.
One of the challenges I've
found as within development
is that people would
allocate research money
to the sort of work that
that Ed is doing very well
it's that this stuff is not mainstream.
And most of the people who
worked in my department
this is a little bit outside
their area of expertise.
So very basic questions
on whether they are
very proud about are you
a disciple of Jane Jacobs?
Do you believe that what you need to do
is create cities with mixed use
or are you supporting the kind of zoning
that you see in American cities
no conversations that most
development professionals
are very comfortable engaging in
and don't really have a view on.
And if they end up giving money
to the ministry of urban
development in Afghanistan
they don't have a very strong opinion
on whether they're gonna be guiding them
towards a more pedestrian
based mixed use approach
or whether they are
going to be allowing them
to develop huge banks
for affordable housing long
way from the city center.
So maybe Ed do you want to come in on that
and or maybe there's a Kate
thing, Ed I don't know?
- I can certainly say something
I certainly have been a fan
of Jane Jacobs all my life
and certainly all my adult life.
And it's being keenly
aware of the failures
of top-down planning, I think is important
but shouldn't make you anti-sure right.
Those are very different things
and you can simultaneously admire.
the use of ninth soil by farmers
in China goes back 1500
years of sanitation
being brought to Chinese cities by farmers
coming into the middle of the
night and taking that out,
nonetheless but this sort of work on,
how the amazing mortality
effects that clean water had
in the 19th century.
And there's just no way of doing that
that isn't in some sense, top-down
it was done by cities, not
by the federal government.
And it was enormously expensive.
America cities and towns were spending
as much on clean water at
the start of the 20th century
as the federal government
was spending on everything
except for the post office in the army.
And I think it's just really important
that we approach issues
like global public health
with a ruthless pragmatism
that issues any particularly
ideological focus, right?
And that means there are some things
that are really best done by
the community for the community
in a way that is bottom up and creative.
And there's some things in which
you really do need to expect to do
massive amounts of investment.
If we're going to get rid of
the risks of global pandemic.
But I will also say just
in terms of what you're saying, Rory,
we are the past 15 years
have been great ones for urban economics.
And we have had a flowering
of fantastic young scholars
who mean that the next 10 years,
we're gonna have a lot more to say
to whether or not it's to the World Bank
are different on this than 15 years ago.
- Thanks Ed I wanted to just
piggyback on your point that
some things are best done
by and for the community
and others with massive
amounts of investment.
I wanna bring some
audience questions in here,
I think we're starting
to get at this question.
But one question coming in is
building on what Rory had to say
is the answer to push toward these large
expensive infrastructure projects.
Should this become the focus
of organizations like DFID ?
And we've touched on this a little bit
and I think we have different views
on this panel, which is great.
Kate was mentioning earlier that
this top-down framing hasn't necessarily
been proven to work
and we need to look for
bottom up solutions.
And Ed was just talking about
the need for both approaches
and just wanted to bring in
this audience question on
would the way forward be for DFID
and other agencies to focus on large
expensive infrastructure projects
or I suppose to reframe what
is the most helpful role
that development agencies could play.
And I think each of you
might have different
views on that question.
- Do you want me to start.
I think the first question
really for any organization
is what is it actually good at?
And what does it know?
I mean, you can have a five or 10 years
changed the culture of organization,
but you have to begin by getting a sense
of what it can do well, and
one of the problems is that
typically in development agencies
is that we are driven by passion.
So every five or years,
we suddenly decided
we ought to be doing something else.
In DFID case look, obviously
there is a strong argument
for infrastructure, but
the truth of matter is that
we've spent 20 years, not
really doing infrastructure.
We don't have people who
really know how to do dams
and bridges and sewage projects.
It's not our expertise.
We have people who have
specialized in governance,
specialized in healthcare
and education specialize in cash transfer.
To some extent, if we're gonna do that.
One of the key things is to make sure that
you're working with the development banks
that really have the emphasis
that the other thing I'd say
given that we've referred a
little bit to biodiversity
and the title of this is it's
very important to understand
that we haven't fully
internalized the arguments
the environmental movement against
the loss of what we've
been doing in development.
So it's remarkable that
very very progressive
development professionals
are still pushing
for agricultural extension
programs, which are horrifying
to the environmental movement
in terms of the types of
pesticides and fertilizers.
That's suggesting of the types
of crops that they're funding.
It's also true that there's
a very, very odd discussion
going on between our energy development,
people who are still pushing to develop
have the oil electricity
generation plants,
and compared to our climate people,
incredible tensions between
people in our organizations
who want to build dams
and irrigation systems
and the environmental
movement pointing out
that these things that
are often going to lead
to huge catastrophes.
So it's interesting, I find
within these organizations
that there isn't really
a space for intellectual debate
where these things are resolved.
What you actually have is
often two, quite separate
specialized departments,
deeply disagreeing with each other,
but rarely actually having the opportunity
to make these arguments
openly and come in front of each other.
- Great point and a big challenge
just kind of gets back to what
we were discussing earlier
when Kate mentioned plants
instead of parking lots
but in terms of how we get
there, when you have people
with different interests pushing
for one thing or the other
including agricultural extension,
as we already mentioned
there are real challenges in
terms of getting to that vision
for the more positive
role cities could play.
Kate or Sunil any reactions
to what Rory just said.
And otherwise we'll bring in
some more questions go a head.
- Yeah it seems like one
of the biggest obstacles
and excuse me, as Sunil
it seems like one of the
biggest obstacles is that
so much of development work.
And so much of the way we think
of where economies should go
is how do we turn people into consumers?
How do we sell more things
and how do we get people to consume
rather than thinking of people as...
What do we do with people
who produce for themselves
who don't really produce for markets
who aren't making anyone a profit
who recycle their manure their feces,
their seeds, their soils
who produced a good part of what they eat,
who build their own houses,
who walk and bike places?
What do we do with them?
I mean if we need people to be consuming
to produce profits for other entities,
that's the big our big
obstacle is the illogical.
I think once we start
thinking about mutual aid
and cooperative societies,
then we have another whole realm
a whole pallet of solutions to come upon.
- I like that quickly I'll just say,
when Rory said that that
the space for intellectual
debate is lacking sometimes.
Kate, you just brought
up a good point that
when you kind of shift your mindset
it unlocks new solutions.
and if we don't have these
kinds of conversations
we don't even see those
potential solutions.
So go ahead, Sunil.
- I just want to pick up
on what Rory was saying
and Kate also touched on
in terms of the kind of
disconnected thinking,
and to turn that back to your question,
Catherine, about obstacles
and I think we need to
acknowledge sometimes
that the obstacles are very serious ones,
the lawns most recent report estimates
that 1.6 million people in India diet
because of air pollution last year.
And it seems to me that the
specific problem of pollution
in country like India, just
take that as an example,
is almost sort of worst of both worlds
because you have that as a combined
and conjoined product of rural poverty,
including energy, poverty.
I mean a lot of this is black carbon
being burned domestically.
It's about crop burning
but it's also about completely
unrestrained automobile
use in India cities.
And I wonder in which what
kind of problem does pollution
pose for development?
I mean, I think that there
are all sorts of ways in which
and if we think about public health,
we're thinking about cities,
we need to be thinking
about the air as well.
And it just seems to me
a quintessential example
of how multiple agendas
might be pushing in very
different directions,
because on the one hand
one of the arguments
is that the reason why
a crop burning has increased
significantly in India
over the last 20 years or so
is because of the green revolution.
It's because of the third annual crop.
It's because of the ways in which,
the nature of the agricultural system
has been pushing in that way.
On the other hand, there's
this sort of urban rural divide
where you have the politicians
and Delhi blaming Haryana and Punjab
for the pollution in Delhi
which is only really
one part of the problem.
So again this is just a call
from all of these kinds of conversations,
which point out some of the contradictions
that I think that sort of
often leading these negative outcomes,
rather than the kinds of synergies
that both Kate had in their
different ways for talking about
- Some, not amazingly the
anti-poverty program and Riga
Actually appears to be somewhat
to blame for air pollution.
So this is the work of Patrick
Bayer at the world bank
that is very well-meaning program
to raise wages for ordinary Indians,
by raising the cost of
labor intensive agriculture
shifted to move to capital
intensive agriculture.
That was actually worse
for the environment.
I just wanted to follow
up on Rory's comment.
And clearly I'm sort of the most..
I seem to be the most
pro infrastructure person
on this on this panel,
but even I am not particularly
in favor of DFID ,
all of a sudden getting
into the world bank
circa 1955 kinds of businesses.
The thing that DFID can bring
is the part of infrastructure
that it actually knows
which is the governance part.
I mean, infrastructure is
not just about structure.
It's about what are the institutions
that you're using to
manage that infrastructure
and what are the incentives
you're putting into place
to get people to connect
to that infrastructure.
And that's a ubiquitous
problem in the developing world
that you'll build a water main
and you'll have a white elephant project
that people aren't connected to.
This was exactly the same problem
that New York faced in the 1840s, 1850s,
when it built the Croton Aqueduct
and 1000s and 1000s of poor
New Yorkers didn't connect
and continue to die of cholera.
In fact, my great, great
great grandfather died of cholera in 1849.
And in New York seven years
after the Croton Aqueduct open, right?
You needed to have a
policy new York's case
which actually penalized tenement owners
who didn't connect to the water system
to actually close that last mile problem.
In some cases might want subsidies instead
but in any case, that
is the business of DFID
it is to think about things like that
and to figure out what
our reasonable lessons
that can be drawn from the history,
both in the developing world
and the developed world.
- Thank you, Ed, so we've heard these--
(mumbles)
Go a head Rory.
- I mean, on that, I think
we'll say there is a question
around community mobilization.
I mean, an enormous amount
of what works in Kabul
and actually getting people
to connect to water supply
or connect to electricity
or connect to sewerage
in volts and very patient conversations
almost household by household
and really trying to understand
why it is people didn't want to connect
what they were worried about
but they worried about
the fact they'd be caught
in some taxation net,
was that the cost of the connection
that was putting them off
was it some dispute the
neighbor, if a landownership
through which the pipe was moving
that too is something that
is sort of counter-intuitive in a way that
if infrastructure is
often led by engineers
they're often people who don't necessarily
have an intuitive feeling for how you work
house to house in a poor area.
I mean I remember working with
a sewage engineer in Kabul
who kept saying it's splendid
kind of jump and sewage engineer
who kept saying in relation
to almost everything,
but this doesn't make sense.
Why wouldn't they do this right?
And sometimes self skills to
get around this question of
but this doesn't make sense
why isn't this happening
in the logical way that
I expect essentially.
- Yeah great point.
I wanted to get your take on
kind of circling back to
what we discussed earlier,
why this topic, why now?
So Sunil mentioned air pollution
and the health implications
of air pollution
being increasingly clear.
We also have, COVID-19
serving as a wake-up call
and these interactions between human
and animals happening in
ways they haven't before.
So we've talked about some
of the challenges, right?
These conversations not happening,
or maybe some of these organizations
not leaning into their skill sets
for how they could best
address this problem
or seize this opportunity.
What's your sense of whether,
beyond this conversation we're having
or conversations that seem
to happen kind of on the sidelines, right?
Not in the mainstream in terms
of ensuring that urbanization
and sustainable development are actually
working in cooperation with one another
is this an opportunity for real change?
Do you get a sense that read,
any kind of turning point
there's any momentum here
that there's an opportunity
or as part of the problem that
this is going to remain on the sidelines,
not in the mainstream?
- Well, one of the most
Google phrases in 2020
in Russian was how do you plant potatoes?
And I think there has been this return to
people are stuck at home.
People are returning to
their immediate environments
and starting to sort of delve in
I think we're where you now
know that we can make changes
at a lightning speed on a global scale
in ways that we hadn't
thought were possible before
when it comes to a global
public health situation.
As Sunil pointed out,
we have global public
health crises all the time
that have to do with poisoned environments
but those are slow public health problems.
We really only seem to be good
when it's infectious
diseases is immediate.
It strikes person, you know, one day.
And then the next day there
a major difference in health.
It's the slow sicknesses
that have to do with contaminants,
congealing, and lungs
contaminants going into flesh
and slowly creating cancers
and tumors auto-immune disorders.
Those are the problems that
we've been really bad about dealing with.
And that I would hope that the pandemic
would get us to focus on.
And then I think we would
maybe reorient our priorities
less to the emergency situation
and more to the long slow violence
of environmental problems.
- Great framing of why now is different
and what we've learned in this moment.
Did others wanna jump in on that?
I think Rory maybe--
- One thing I suppose that strikes me
is in thinking this
through, it's very important
to try to put yourself in the mindset
of somebody working in the municipality
of the developing country
and really try to think
through what's going on.
So that could include, for example
at an extreme level corruption, right?
Many, many people in municipality
are extremely poorly paid.
And many of the decisions
that they're making
maybe taking place in the context of them
having multiple jobs
or being under pressure
from property developers,
finances even in somewhere like London,
a lot of very very poor
planning decisions are made
because the mayor of
London is short of cash
and wants to try to make money
from property developments illegally.
Rates money this is rates
money, revenue money,
and will therefore authorize,
it's huge tower blocks
and places where nobody
wants to tower block
and where they can see an
most amount of problems
but that's the way they make the money
problems of the poverty of a population.
So many, many things will get stuck
because it's very difficult to work out.
Whether you can generate an income stream
will people pay for that water rates
will people pay for their
(mumbles)
How do they do that
problems with different
levels of government?
So there will often be clashes between
the sort of sub district
level on the meth team
and standoffs on who has
legal power to do what
and finally problems with ideology.
You will have often somebody
may be very well-meaning.
They may well not be corrupt.
They may be trying to do the right thing
but in Afghanistan, the meth
that I worked with in 2003
had trained in East Germany
and his mindset was still
very, very much influenced
by his training in the 1970s
and early 1980s in East Germany
and in particular, his idea
of what it meant to be modern.
And a lot of what he was doing
was trying to resist any
attempts for foreigners to impose
what he thought was an old fashioned
or sort of, and by modern he meant
sort of extraordinary
high East German mentality
of the mid 1980s.
Anyway, that's just some random thoughts
but I think locating it in the
culture of the municipality
and its mindsets is important.
- I think that's very important.
And I appreciate that point.
I wanna bring in a
question from the chat that
Ed generously answered in the chat,
but for those who are joining
us on line, not in the Zoom
I wanna make sure to elevate this point.
So one of the questions coming in is
what are the mistakes
or lessons learned from past strategies
that inform future planning initiatives
and public investment?
I mean, great question,
because that's exactly
what we're trying to get
at by bringing historians
and practitioners together,
understanding lessons from
history to inform practice
and Ed I wonder not to put you on the spot
but do you mind just expanding on your
I think very thoughtful
response in the chat
and then we'll see if
others want to jump in.
- Sure I mean as has
already been alluded to
the litany of development
errors is just enormous, right?
We have an enormous number of mistakes.
I do not share the view that
Western cities are failures
but it is certainly true
that there have been
a massive number of
mistakes have been made.
If I was going to pull
the sort of meta error
it would be the failure to
plan for the needs of humanity
and a focus on structures,
as opposed to people when building
ultimately cities are flesh and blood,
they are not made of concrete and steel.
And ultimately when you
allow engineers or builders
or economists to build
for the sake of building
rather than to build for the needs
of the real people in the
city, then you screw up.
And I think in some sense
that's the way to think about
sort of some of the worst excesses
of post-war urban planning.
That being said, as we
look around the world today
there are sort of two variants of this
one of which is monumentalism.
And if you want an extreme version of this
you can look at Astana for example, right.
Sort of building vast towers
to glorify the Monarch
to glorify the ruler it's an
old practice in human history.
I would say that most of the time
where you see sort of large capitals
that they are guilty of it,
but there's another scene
which is nimbyism which is opposition
to any tall building whatsoever.
And this is something which
as much as I I derived East
German planning practices
it is also true that
borrowing from Yorkshire
is not particularly
wise from Mumbai either.
And yet the UK at Town
and Country Planning Act
was indeed the model
from Mumbai is a planning act in 1968.
And consequently Mumbai has labored
under a 1.25 floor area restriction
which means that the average height
of new billings has to be one
a quarter, which is massive.
It doesn't stop.
Part of the reason that was imposed
was the hope that would
restrict urban growth in Mumbai.
Of course, it didn't.
It just led to a dysfunctional city
now as has been frequently said,
I yield to no one in my admiration
for the genius of
ordinary Indian urbanites
who figure out amazing things
to do in places like Dharavi
but they have often been
failed by their governments
which have often just
made it too difficult
to actually do the building
to do the city shaping
that's needed to survive.
And that's both of these errors.
Aren't the silhouette and corruptness
of sort of urban growth out there.
One of which is building
for the sake of building
the second of which is not building
because you have some ideal of some city
that you would imagine that
can only exist if we restrict
people from adding density.
- Thank you, Ed.
I'm glad we elevated that
question from the chat.
And I was eager to hear
a more expanded answer
from what you wrote in the chat.
Unless anyone else wanna jump in on that.
I wanna bring in another
question from our audience
which specifically narrows
in on food systems.
When we talk about lessons
from history to inform practice
I know that's something Kate
has provided a few examples of,
but this person asks
in many low and middle income countries,
one of the key ways in which urbanization
affects the environment is through food
because cities have to be fed
urbanization often comes together
with rapid agricultural intensification
and the development of
food transport and trade
putting pressure on the environment.
We've heard some examples of this
any insights on how aid can
help feed cities sustainably.
Great very specific question
any thoughts on that?
I'll see, who wants to jump
in perhaps Rory or Kate?
- Oh, do you mind if--
- Go for it, Kate?
- Well, my sense is in this
whole discussion is that,
you can fix this and you can fix that
and you can get $40 a year to someone
but if you keep producing
and bleeding poor people
if economic systems keep doing that
there's always gonna be
a development problem
no matter what infrastructure
you put in place.
So I guess my pitches for
re-localizing economies
turning large-scale production systems
that make corporations phenomenal profits
that usually go to big cities in the West
and in the North and making
small scale productive streams.
So what urban farmers do,
they produce local diverse
organic food on marginal land
with short market chains
and few post-harvest losses.
They use very few fossil fuels to do that.
They don't dump pesticides
and herbicides on their crops.
They make affordable,
nutritious, and fresh food.
That's consumed right there,
10 feet from where it was produced.
The only problem with that system
is it doesn't make Wall Street
or other markets big entities money
but it does produce wealth and wellness.
- Rory did you want to jump in?
- Yeah I mean I'm deeply
sympathetic towards Kate,
but I suppose the two issues
that are normally raised
in the policy conversation
of anxieties around cost
but generally the idea is that
modern industrial farming
techniques and scale
result in cheaper food for consumers.
The second thing is that oddly
there is now quite a strong movement
from part of the environmental movement
against low intensity organic farming.
So George Monbiot for example, in Britain
is a real ugly a real supporter
of Heidi intensive industrial agriculture
because he thinks that
the most efficient way
of using limited land and it frees up
the rest of the land for re-wilding.
So there are sort of two models.
There's the model which I
fit, which is closer to Kate
which is a more low
intensity organic land use.
The alternative model is
that you sort of divide your country up
between Kansas and Alaska.
You go for the kind of
crazy industrial agriculture
in one place, and then
you have these huge areas
occupied by wolves in another area.
And it's all that actually
the environmental movement
can't quite which of those two
models that wishes to pursue
and quite articulate
advocates environments
that some Monbiot favor,
industrial agriculture.
- I don't have any views on agriculture
but I do want to just point out
the similarity between the
argument Rory just made.
And part of the case for urban density
is that by bringing people
more closely together in cities
we believe more land
alone for nature, right?
So you're in some sense the mantra is
if you love nature, stay away from it.
As indeed human beings are
very destructive species.
I like to tell the story
of Henry David Thoreau
burning up 400 acres of prime
Woodlands as part of his
enjoying melding with nature thing.
The same point is about
sort of living densely
means less carbon emissions
and actually means being kinder to nature
and means leaving more land
available for wild things.
- Thank you, Ed so I'm gonna
bring in one more question
and then we only have a
few minutes left here.
So I'll bring up this
question for consideration
but we'd love each of you to
close with any key message
you want this audience to walk away with.
So the question is around
what came up earlier
moving to a bottom up
view of this connection
between urbanization and
sustainable development.
And the question is with many governments
now focusing on infrastructure projects,
particularly in the UK
are there good examples
of bottom-up funded
infrastructure projects
that we can look to?
So again, just a question
on examples models.
So would welcome any thoughts on that
but with just five minutes left
I'd love to just go
back to each of you for
a quick point you want the
audience to walk away with
a call to action maybe
for how things could be done differently.
Given that I think there
is some opportunity here
for us to think differently
and maybe act differently on this topic.
So we'll close with Sunil
because he helped to bring us together
but I'll look to Kate, Ed, Rory
see who wants to jump in
first, any final thoughts.
And if you have a particular example
others should take a look at
as we leave our conversation today
there seems to be an interest
in some specific examples and models.
So Rory, can we start with you?
- Yeah so I think that the
thing that is important
is to understand how unresolved
is discovered things up.
So really important to understand
within a bureaucratic department,
that we don't really explore
the fact that we disagree.
And there are suggestions
if this actually in this conversation,
I suspect that if we
had another three for us
has been cheeky
Ed and Kate don't agree on everything,
but often within a department
those disagreements are not
fully brought to the fall.
There will be disagreements,
which from technical
right disagreements on what works,
there'll be disagreements on priorities.
Some people may be worried
about the gut by him.
And another person may be
more worried about income
expressed in cash terms but
there will also be normative
or moral disagreements
to deal with your entire
conception of values,
which very, very rarely any role at all
in discussions within mentation.
And so I think this is quite useful.
And I think if we can acknowledge that
although we share a lot and we agree a lot
we also disagree and
bring up his disagreements
is an important part of progress.
And that will be my
contribution, thank you.
- I agree.
Ed or Kate, who wants to jump in quickly
and we do have to keep our
remarks pretty short here
but can I go to you Kate
and then we'll go to Ed?
- Sure well, just in closing,
I think these last remarks,
I think we need to point out that
the history of environmentalism itself
is a little dark and very
much an elitist agenda
that we just saw sketched out.
You have dense urban cities,
super that leaves you
all of Alaska free for wildlife,
who gets to go to Alaska
only the elite who can
afford those expensive trips
to Alaska and everybody else's
is in their concrete jungle.
I think we need to rethink
environmentalist and think of it
a new kind of working
class environmentalist
where people have on
the ground made really
sort of brilliant new technologies
and advances and innovations
that have been missed in plain sight.
That's just all, I'm trying to point out.
- Thank you, Kate, Ed we'll go to you.
- Sure I just have really
three points and I'll be fast.
One of which is where I started
which is that this pandemic reminds us
that we are all of us on
this planet in this together.
And in fact, if that does
not renew the commitment
of the wealthy countries of the West
towards investing in and learning from
and being part of a
development process together
then it is an opportunity terribly missed.
The second point is there is
no escaping our urban future.
It is there and even if you don't like it,
and I very much do like it.
I think that that is the best
chance we have for cultural,
political change as well as prosperity
as well as a world of hope
rather than a world of fear,
it is there.
And we need to approach it
with a ruthless pragmatism
as I've said earlier,
that is non ideological
and very much focused on solutions
that improve the lives
of ordinary urbanites
throughout the planet.
And the third point I wanna make is that,
yes we absolutely do want bottom up things
as often as possible
but you're not gonna crowd
source COVID-19 vaccine, right?
It's something that's gonna be produced
with cutting edge technology
and we need that too.
And so we must not forget our desire
to like ground up things.
And I very much do believe
in the Jane Jacobs vision
of neighborhoods taking
responsibility for their own
that we also sometimes need
governments that work right?
And in some sense, what
we are seeing around us
in most of the world with
the COVID-19 pandemic
is a massive public failure.
And that we cannot
respond to that by saying,
we gonna look for bottom up innovation.
We need to actually get our governments
to be more functional as well.
- Thank you, Ed.
Sunil we'll go to you.
I think we have different visions
of what to do in this moment of time
but agreement that it's
a moment of opportunity.
And so can you just give
any final thoughts on
again as we started,
why this topic, why now?
And what's the way forward.
- One thing I've learned
from this conversation
one for conversation is
that the visions matter.
I mean, I'm thinking
about Rory is this
German trained engineer,
I think our visions of human flourishing
at this moment need to be made explicit
and need to be put into
conversation with one another
and the sort of conflicts
within that I think,
upfront and recognized.
And I think this is a
moment of opportunity
but I think it's also a moment of alarm
because I think
I am struck by what
Kate was saying earlier.
We've made quite clear we
can respond to a pandemic
but there are crises that
kill many many more people
than COVID-19 has so far
terrible though it has been
about which has been
total, total inaction.
And I would like to see us sort of pivot
towards thinking about
some of those quieter,
less sort of immediate crises
which have to do with the
relationship between environment
and for human health and human wellbeing.
- Thanks Sunil this is one
of those conversations
I wish we could continue
but we are out of time.
So I just wanna thank our panelists
for their time and expertise
and thank our attendees for your time
and attention and great questions.
This is definitely one of
those topics that benefits
from bringing historians
and practitioners together
and it was a pleasure to moderate.
So thank you all and we'll see you
in the next edition of the
Yale development dialogues.